chris flexon he has been rock solid all
season for the mariners and era of 3-8-1
on the season just outside of the top 10
in the american league land junior
climbs in two outs nobody on scoreless
top of the first flexon into the wind-up
and the pitch
swinging this is slice deep high out to
right field hannigan drifting back again
out of the warning track hannigan curls
underneath leaps
he makes the catch what a sensational
grab
to take a hit away from vlad junior up
against the wall
and with that flexon retires his side in
order for the bottom of the first
scoreless ray the second best era in the
american league it's under three
he's punched out 159 on the season here
is hannigan who just made that play in
right field
the o2 pitch
fastball swinging a miss
hanukkah couldn't touch 95 first
strikeout on the night
for robbie ray
that brings up ty france he's had good
success in his career against robbie ray
5 for 10 lifetime with a couple of home
runs
3-2
sliders swinging a miss
back-to-back strikeouts for robbie ray
to cap off a perfect first and we're
underway in seattle blue jays have
thrown out a four-man outfield
santiago espinol is playing in the
outfield grass against seeger
3-2 swinging a miss got him with a
fastball but right underneath the
knuckles third straight strikeout for
robbie ray
that brings up the top of the order as
the boos
once again great george springer
his 2-2 pitch
swung on cracked into the gap in left
center field kellick racing back
reaching up not the track and he reels
it in he makes the catch taking away
extra bases from george springer
[Applause]
manor's outfield getting it done so far
tonight a couple of beauties a one two
three third we go to the bottom of the
inning no score
aubry ray the second best era in the
american league and the mariners have a
golden opportunity here
a runner at second base no outs and here
comes tom murphy
he'll stand in from the right side
against the lefty
here's the one two
swung on and hammered down the left
field line this has a chance to go it is
good
just below the scoreboard down the left
field line a two-run blast tom murphy
and the mariners have taken the lead it
is two to nothing seeger's having a big
second half home run total only behind t
oscar hernandez and george springer
1-2 swinging a miss got him with a
slider seekers down for the second time
on strikes and the inning comes to a
close but not before seven men get to
the plate and one big swing from tom
murphy gave this contest to score his
two-run home run puts the mariners in
front early 2-0
one out two in scoring position for
who has just been an rbi monster to
oscar hernandez who leads the league in
ribbies in the second half he's singled
earlier he's got two in scoring position
with one down
bucks and comes set
the two two
kind of miss ooh the column strike three
on the lower inside corner it just
clipped it and hernandez can't believe
it he's slow to exit as he's walking up
to our home plate umpire jim reynolds
puts one hand on the small of his back
has a quick word
and right now
guriel is on an upward trend for the
blue jays with the bat
right-handed here patiently waiting
flexons 1-1
a breaking ball rolled towards the
middle of the diamond through into
center field of base head vlady scores
to get the blue jays on the board but
jets right behind him to tie the game on
a two-run single
by lourdes gorilla
elise torrens at the plate
ray throws
and the pitch is slugged in the air
straight away center field springer back
through the track at the wall he leaves
and he makes the catch george springer
with a leaping grab at the wall and
straightaway center field
he robs torrens of extra bases
jared kellnick the 22 year old rookie
who doubled off of ray
back in the third inning
now bats here in the fourth they'll win
kellnik hits it sharply down to first
fairball stepping on the back guriel
steps to throw down to second the tag on
toro and he's out
an inning ending double play brilliantly
done by lourdes gorilla jr
he's flashing the leather right on top
of the cushion he lands on the bag from
his knees throws down to second and a
tag applied on toro to retire the side
here comes marcus simeon
[Applause]
mariners two blue jays two two outs
richik at second
plexus one two
strike three call
he gets simeon looking and he strands
gretchik's double he carves for the blue
jays after grincha gets to second and he
keeps the jays off the board in the
fifth tom murphy their catcher turned
around to robbie ray fastball and hit it
out to left field back in the third
3-2
strike three call got it on the top part
of the zone
this strikeout tonight for robbie ray
murphy goes down looking
here's the number nine batter dylan
moore 02. swinging a miss
back to back strikeouts for robbie ray
one looking one swing burial drove in
the two runs in the fourth inning with a
base hit
he's one for two in the game
one ball two strikes the shet his lead
at first base flex and ready
he deals
swinging a miss got him the cutter down
in the dirt
down goal is giriel and the blue jays
put away here in the sixth inning
strikeout number three for flexon he
continues a nice night here at t-mobile
park
hanagar missed all of last season
because of back surgery
the pitch
swinging a miss
another strikeout for robbie ray
he's fanned three out of the last four
he's got seven punch-outs on the night
simeon tonight at ground out to third
base it to left in a strikeout looking
runners take off the 3-2 swing and a
miss a vicious slider in the dirt simeon
slams his helmet to the ground and
castillo gets the punch out and that's a
big one blue jays kept off the board in
the seventh simeon punches out castillo
gets it done here in the frame
we go to the bottom of the seventh we
are still tied to a beast now luis
torrence 02 swinging a missed good
morning good afternoon good night three
pitches
torrance into the glove strikeout number
eight the bases are now loaded for
marcus simeon second rider sets now
fires
swinging a soft pop-up foul ground
france racing over angling back and he
makes the basket catch valera tags
here's a throw home in time tag applied
he's safe murphy can't believe it
murphy's pointing to the mariners dugout
they will challenge this
if it's overturned it's a double play to
in the inning i would be shocked if his
call
was overturned yeah
here's the call
they call him out
they call him out at home
amazing
amazing
and now it's the rookie jared koelnik
with a chance to win it for the mariners
with two outs and the bases loaded
in the ninth inning the 3-0 pitch from
grand hand
ball
they walked them and the mariners win it
three to two
bases loaded walk darren kelvik walks it
off
you